Efficiency is perhaps the most important
concept I'll teach you in this course.
So make sure you understand
it before moving on.
Efficiency, also called complexity,
is how well you're using your computer's
resources to get a particular job done.
You can normally think about
it in terms of space and time.
How long does your code take to run,
and how much storage space do you need?
Let's think about efficiency
in terms of cutting hair.
Normally, your hair would be
snipped off in clumps, and
you would just compare some strands you
cut to a group you're about to cut,
to approximate where your next cut goes.
However, you could cut one
strand of hair at a time and
compare each strand to a ruler or
measuring tape,
to make sure the exact same amount
gets cut every single time.
That's ridiculous, though.
It would take a crazy amount of time,
and
it really doesn't matter if
hair is exactly, precisely cut.
If you could use less time to get the
job done pretty well, than you're good.
Often, the tradeoffs for
algorithm efficiency are similar.
You could take a slow,
methodical approach, but there's
often a faster method that accomplishes
the same goal by reducing repetition.
Efficiency can rely heavily on your
creativity and your ability to get
the most done with minimal resources,
but there are a lot of known tips and
tricks that you'll be expected to
know in a technical interview.
An interviewer will expect you to
know some common data structures and
the efficiency of doing
basic things with them,
as well as some knowledge of
specific well known algorithms.
In this case, an algorithm is just
a series of steps for solving a problem.
One of my favorite moments
in my programming career
was the first time I used
an algorithm to improve my code.
I had a function that took hours
to run on this huge dataset.
But after applying an algorithm,
it only took seconds.
Writing really efficient code can come
off with another tradeoff between
time efficiency and space efficiency.
What if your code could run in
just a fraction of the time
by storing temporary values
in a new data structure?
For that decision, you would need to
weigh whether the time of the person
using your code or the amount of
memory needed is more important.
By the end of this course,
you'll have most of the tools and
knowledge you need to
make efficient code.